this is kind of cool because sometimes
when you're in movies you don't know
people but y'all been friends for a
while right yeah long time yeah when did
y'all meet well well do you have
different stories uh Katherine revealed
to me only a month ago oh that's right
we met a long time ago that she asked
for a photo of my twin and I at Bob's
Big Boy in Los Angeles I was around
seven years old huge fan obviously who
wasn't right everyone
here's um and I'm lucky enough to
one of the people who got a picture with
the sprous twins I didn't remember the
moment no and I didn't tell him about it
until way way into filming because I
wanted to like be cool you know I wanted
to we're both actors like we're the same
we're not the same we not the not at all
well you you did a photo shoot with
because he's a photographer we talked
about this last time but you did a a
photo shoot with him and it kind of was
like inspiring for this whole movie
right I um you know I I've seen Cole
multiple times throughout the years we
met again when he was on River D and I
was on Supernatural and he kept talking
about my poodles cuz I have these crazy
dogs and finally I asked you to just
shoot and he shot it in my house with
these wigs and it was like you came up
with this narrative like a woman who
killed all her husbands and it's just
collecting dogs and diamonds you know um
and I feel like it was a precursor to
our film cuz yeah I got to talk to my
therapist about that IDE yeah there's a
lot to dive in there
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home